foreign
I like the positivity in the room that
in some ways all three of you are
hopeful that we can know ourselves I'm
going to be thoroughly and utterly
negative so I'm gonna say that we cannot
it's not possible for us to know
ourselves it's dangerous it's
potentially extremely dangerous to uh to
try to do so and neither is it desirable
it's not something we should try to do
and I'm gonna give two reasons for why
it's uh not possible and can lead to all
kinds of complications one of them is
that uh not it's a bit extremely
invested and biased when it comes to to
knowing ourselves uh because it's us
we're trying not to have any negative
opinions of ourselves so um so there is
something that psychologists call
psychological immune system
and the idea there is that if there's if
you're bombarded with the negative
information about ourselves then we're
just going to swat them away because we
don't want to have negative informations
about ourselves so uh so self-knowledge
is uh not like other kinds of knowledge
other kinds of knowledge you could try
to be neutral when it comes to
self-knowledge it's very difficult to be
neutral you're always uh invested and
it's always distorts uh any kind of
attempt at knowledge the second reason
um is that um the South changes we
change all the time and there's a lot of
uh um interesting social psychology uh
experiments that show this
um from one year to the other and
five-year uh periods there's just
enormous changes that we undergo in all
kinds of ways including personality
traits uh including very the you know
the most touchy feely or most
touchy-feely uh cherished taste in music
and in literature and it felt huge
changes um I don't agree with Ben say on
much uh really because he seems so
extraordinarily black and white
um the picture is subtler than that and
and
um it's quite true that we deceive
ourselves of course we deceived
ourselves about many things but not to
make the attempt to see more truly it
doesn't follow logically from the fact
that we often deceive ourselves I I
think some people are actually very good
at knowing themselves I I've known many
in in my life some people seem to have
to have no talent for it at all it's a
matter of degree and it varies also the
point about change yes but everything
changes everything flows but it doesn't
necessarily become something utterly
different I think the extent to which uh
change was stressed there exaggerated
things so badly that it almost
um reached the conclusion that it wanted
to reach by just saying well you change
so much there's no continuity with
yourself I would say that doesn't stand
up philosophically live psychologically
nor do I think that it's dangerous to do
so because you will you'll take a very
high opinion of yourself I've worked a
lot of my life with people who take a
rather poor opinion of themselves much
poorer than they need to and and getting
it right is important getting it wrong
is dangerous yes but you don't have to
get it wrong that whole premise is is
far too simplistic and overdriven and
finally I don't know what country events
they comes from but in most languages
other than English we make a distinction
in kinds of knowledge there is knowledge
in the sense of German vison and French
savoir but there is also knowledge in
the sense of German Canon and French
connect and it is that process that we
need to exercise and getting to know
ourselves it's not an alienating one it
is a human one one that has relationship
in it and I think that's just it's
really important just take take the
stories that we tell ourselves I.E this
kind of self-knowledge stuff less
seriously and I and I think that that's
a really important thing and let me tell
you why uh and I'm gonna appeal to
Authority here and the authorities
andrejid he has this really nice
one-liner about how if the caterpillar
were to know itself
it would never become a butterfly
um and that goes back to the point about
change
was a little bit back about different
kinds of knowledge not the kind of uh
linguistic distinction that Ian was
talking about which I don't find
particularly
um helpful or amusing well if tomorrow
you're going to wake up as a little bit
taller than you are would it still be
you if you woke up tomorrow it's blonde
as uh I don't know as a heavy metal fan
as a republican as a Buddhist would that
still be you and then you can kind of
Trace what how what are the features
that people attribute themselves that
they take to be the defining features
and it's very difficult to avoid
thinking of of yourself as having these
kind of defining features you think of
yourself as a as a professor as a
liberal as a vegetarian and so on but
this is exactly the kind of
self-knowledge that uh that andrejit was
talking about if you're kind of labeling
yourself like this and it is true that
you're changing all the time you're
changing
your labeling yourself does not change
So eventually you're there's going to be
this huge conflict between who you are
and who you think you are and that is uh
what's preventing you from becoming a
butterfly all right I'm done
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV